welcome to this video when playing light
like light like from germany vs
ternational mastered some Xander yes
Martin someone alright let's see we got
a classical French and this Bishop e7
line recently good recommended in this
book which I have just got yesterday and
it's quite quite interesting that this
line is is analyzed because it's um yeah
it always had them this kind of outdated
reputation I'm only playing it tough I
don't know I did I didn't really study
anything get in this book it's um it's
um written long by grandmaster our guard
and a Greek a theoretician in the till
is not quite sure i'm probably
mispronouncing this terribly ok so he
castled short it's not so common in the
sun in this line white very often goes
with long castling ok i could have taken
on d phone but Miguel goes naughty too
and probably gets it back huh maybe he's
preparing to even play g4g 4 + f5
possible
okay so let's uh let's take here and see
how is going to to get its material back
I can play Quincy five on yeah the night
on be success William very debatable how
well the side pieces is placed okay for
the moment let's prevent f5 he can take
in but I don't think it's it's such a
big problem I hope that done I can get
my bishop out on b5 to get it exchanged
but that's an interesting move does he
have a discovered the tech by the snide
I'm not sure I better protect the Queen
like night f5 or something this was
really an idea five was a threat Queen
f2 and 96 check so I have the Queen
protected
yeah I wonder if he can play something
really drastic like g4g for that five
maybe
trying to provoke weaknesses him and if
possible reroute the night like that and
then Bishop b5 should be five just takes
it that's surprising didn't expect that
I care of course and I was a it was a
skier he needed to take I'm sorry it's
still early here early in the day I just
have I'm just having my first coffee and
I didn't even play a warm-up game just
diving right in yeah yeah
at one point here you need to do
something something serious and he's
doing exactly that now okay how to how
to answer yeah night before some the
normal type of reaction just putting it
in any form until he probably needs to
take he's got f5 though this is some
this is clear that fire maybe I can just
castle but this is a dangerous business
okay but I'll do that anyway it may be
cautious upon them if it takes twice but
I don't really might mind that too much
i also have Queen t5 and taking on a
tune now Queen defy this probably not
bad anyway centralizing the Queen grab
here if he goes at five I'm just going
to Castle I still haven't castle yet
now his King is also is also a bit
exposed of course he's got pieces around
it but there's always potential danger
okay Queen to h6 this is the the
dangerous thing so i'm going to set up
this this pin here and one constant
problem of course is that that the pawn
on f6 is also a big issue in the end
game if it gets traded and he gets some
rook on on an open file as always a
check made on the back rank this is
often now the most serious business with
such an advanced porn that you can you
always have problems in the end game
okay going to see five in order to have
queen evade so should i do that i guess
i should get this out of the picture and
maybe i can even activate now yeah I
don't really want to trade queens my
king come in comparison looks relatively
safe now
yeah I'm intending to go g5 on edge why
not the greatest move ever improving
them
I know I'm just down on 30-something
seconds now I don't know this end game
should be okay actually I get h6 maybe
this one
don't think this should should be a
problem really the position at least
I've got time issues as I'm used to the
position should should be x morning came
check check cause I shouldn't shoot
devil out there check check check check
yeah grah I'll check drug game offered
Ron yeah well offering a draw i
overstepped the time all right yeah well
tough tough game I don't I don't really
know I mean around here I think it
should be should be should be it wrong
but ok we both had 20 seconds this is
this is very tricky of course alright
thanks for watching